We've seen Donald Trump seem confused or lose
his place or forget the words of Psalms and
prayers while in church, but that's sort of
to be expected with Trump. Trump was never
really religious. His entire, the Bible is,
my favorite book thing was obviously a farce
from the get go to appeal to evangelical voters,
which happened to work on them by the way,
which is a whole other problem.
But that, that's all that that was. But the
frequency with which Trump is forgetting words
or confused by words on his own teleprompter,
two feet in front of him is growing in regularity.
And it happened again over the weekend. So
for a second time, Donald Trump is on video
appearing confused and disoriented during
the national Anthem, our national Anthem,
by the way, not the Russian national Anthem.
It might make more sense if he was confused
during that, but uh, or any other, of course.
Why would I mention that one? But during our
national Anthem, this time, it's at a football
game in Alabama. Trump, of course, trying
for the third time in three weeks to go to
a sporting event where something other than
booze and chance of lock him up are hurled
at him. So take a look at the video. You'll
notice Trump stop singing towards the end
of the national Anthem. Sort of seems confused
and kind of starts patting his chest almost
like a nervous, uh, um, uh, anxiety motion.
Everybody around him keeps singing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
this isn't the first time that this has happened
in public back in, uh, January of 2018. Similar
thing happened. We covered it at the time
in the middle of the national Anthem during
a football game in Atlanta, Georgia. Here's
video of that just to remind you.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
so I think you get the idea. So what matters
here? I mean, on the merits. This is not about
patriotism. This isn't some stupid thing of,
unless you know the lyrics by heart, you aren't
a Patriot or anything stupid like that. This
is about Trump continuing to display outwardly
signs of either and I don't know which it
is or it could be both cognitive decline and
or drug addiction. And interestingly, I've
seen more and more speculation lately that
these things are drug addiction, not cognitive
decline. You might remember that a month ago
we brought you the story of Donald Trump's
office being photographed with boxes and boxes
of Sudafed, a particular type of Sudafed that
is actually sold in the UK, the packaging
from the U K stacked up in Donald Trump's
desk behind him, over his left shoulder. And
of course this is something that it is a medication
for a nose congestion, uh, but it can be crushed
up and snorted like a recreational upper.
And I read a bunch of commentaries about this
national Anthem video saying the Trump swaying
and being unable to sit still and unable to
concentrate. It seems more like drug addiction
than cognitive decline. But truly, who knows?
All we know is that it's bad. Republicans
should do the patriotic thing, call it what
it is. It's just, it's a person who's compromised.
That's what we can say for sure. Whether they're
compromised by drugs or cognitive decline
or a life of narcissism, it doesn't really
matter. It doesn't really make a difference
to us at this point. Just put party political
party aside for a second and say we can't
have a president who is so compromised. Now
of course the side story here is once again,
Donald Trump at a sporting event after being
booed at the major league baseball world series
game five a couple of weeks ago at a UFC fight
in New York city last week, desperate to find
a sporting event at which he is not overwhelmingly
booed and he found one in Alabama football,
I guess now there were some reports saying
the reason he wasn't booed is the school say,
sent out a letter saying you will be punished
if you BU the school denies it.
The, the way the letter was worded was anybody
who causes a disruption during Donald Trump's,
uh, visit will be immediately removed from
their seats. And what they're saying is that
that was more about being disruptive to other
students or whatever. But very clearly not
any kind of restriction on free speech. You
be the judge. At least that's the position
that the school is taking on this one. Let
me know what you think. Let me know what you
make of the video. Uh, we will be maybe doing
a poll question on our Instagram account about
this at David Pakman show. Follow David Pakman
show on Instagram. And while you're there,
follow me on Instagram at David dot Pacman.
We will take a quick break. I still want to
talk about Rudy Giuliani or Giuliani and his
latest antics Sean Hannity has over being
implicated in impeachment. We will also talk
about those who claim to be about dialogue,
shutting down dialogue. What a big shocker.
And also I've got some good recommendations
for you today. All of that and more
coming up on today's program